the most game-changing work that I've
ever done is
Marie launched a multi-million dollar
star of the award-winning marietv an
international best-selling author
Marie
track your time meticulously for seven
days you will be shocked at how much
time flitters away that don't create a
ton of value for you and you'll get an
idea of like I would have never thought
of that if your face was stuck in
Netflix or Tick Tock for you know the
seven hours a day that you're not
working your book is full of solutions
to the most important challenges what
are you struggling with
is ADHD so I can have a very overactive
brain I found myself over performing and
over working wanting to control
everything so I could have a sense of
safety that's where the real cost came
in for me I started dreading waking up
in the morning like I wish I could just
disappear like wow yeah see these were
scary thoughts and it almost destroyed
my relationship
in the book you took about these three
rules that underpin this figure outable
mindset yes and it's just helped me in
every different facet my relationships
my mental health my business what are
those so rule number one is that
rule number two
rule number three
that's super important Point number
three it's the one we don't talk about
you have to be willing to just
before this conversation starts I've got
a favor to ask from you 74 of people
that watch this podcast frequently
haven't yet hit the Subscribe button and
nine percent of people haven't yet hit
the Bell to turn notifications on the
bigger this platform gets the bigger the
guests get so if you could do me one
favor if you've ever enjoyed this
podcast please hit the Subscribe button
and turn notifications on without
further Ado I'm Stephen Butler and this
is the Diary of a CEO I hope nobody's
listening but if you are then please
keep this yourself
Murray
when I was reading your book you talk
about how
experience is one of the things that
ends up shaping the beliefs we have in
the world
what were the experiences that you had
at the very earliest of Ages that end up
shaping the beliefs you've had about the
world
one of the biggest ones was actually a
memory I had when I was about seven or
eight years old
so my parents had just gotten a divorce
and I remember being in the kitchen in
my house in New Jersey with my mom and
I'm looking at her and she has one of
the old school phones with the cord like
wrapped around her hand and it was
wrapped around so tight that her hand
was kind of turning white because she
was cutting off the circulation
and she was on the phone with her mother
who was in Florida at the time and she
was crying unconsolably
and I'm watching my mom with tears
running down her face and her everything
looked drawn and she was saying
I have nothing I have nothing do you
understand I have nothing I don't know
what I'm going to do and so you know
there's tears coming down and I'm just
Frozen in fear
he hangs up the phone and she bends down
and I just see like her makeup running
down her face and the tears running down
her face and she puts her hands on my
shoulders and she puts her face right
next to mine up to my nose and she
shakes me
and she says do you see what I'm going
through right now
I have nothing do not be stupid like I
was don't ever let a man don't ever let
anyone control your money I need you to
grow up I need you to be your own woman
I need you to be independent don't be
stupid like me
and Stephen I was just like you know as
a seven or eight year old like in shock
of course I love my dad my dad's an
amazing man and I love my mom and that
experience like in a few seconds I made
all of these equations in my mind and I
made all these decisions and I made all
these promises to myself and I'll tell
you what those were
one of the decisions was that
the lack of having enough money equaled
the loss of love
the destruction of family and so much
pain and suffering like seeing my mom in
pain knowing my dad wasn't there knowing
my family using unit wasn't okay and I
just everything felt unsafe and I made
this promise in this decision I said
okay when I grow up
I'm gonna somehow make so much money
that I am going to take care of the
people I love and if anyone around me
needs money to to handle the pain I'm
going to be able to take care of them
now looking back I'm in my 40s now I can
see how much that fear and how much that
desire to have love be healed has driven
almost every part of my career
to have love be healed yes what do you
mean by that
because I had this notion that because
there wasn't enough money that
my parents love was broken
when we are driven by insecurities
it can be it can get a little bit out of
hand yeah you know when something like
that like money becomes your North Star
um
it almost means that the other stars are
dimmed the other
things that
form our very human needs what was the
cost then of prioritizing that of having
money as a motivator in some ways it was
wonderful because it was there was a
rooting in solid work ethic that was
fabulous and at the same time a
self-punishment
I'm never doing enough
it's not quite enough this is not good
enough it can be better I can be better
and you know for many years especially
early in my career I didn't really have
an off button you know it was working
seven days a week morning until night
um you know missing out on whether it
was friends getting married or this one
or that one and some of that you know
it's complicated it's multi-layered
right A lot of times if friends were
going on let's say a bachelorette party
to Vegas or whatever I legitimately
didn't have the money to go and I found
myself working all the time just to kind
of climb out of debt in the early days
of my business for example so there's a
little bit of give and take there you
know there's the cost and I think
eventually as I started to get into my
40s I started recognizing just this
pattern of over performance of overdoing
of over pushing sometimes I would say to
my partner Josh we've been together for
like 20 years and I would say God you
know I really want to take a break right
now but I've got X Y and Z to do and I
said I don't I just I feel so lazy if I
take a break I can't take a break like
there's so much and he's like Marie you
were one of the most productive non-lazy
people I have ever met in my life no
matter how many times he said that to me
Stephen
for so long I didn't believe him
I was like he's lying he he's not as
productive as I am he has lower
standards than I do which is all not
true
um and it was uh it was tough it was it
was just I wasn't very kind to me
how do you how do you balance that
because on one end you know the feeling
of being not satisfied yeah is
motivating absolutely it means that
you're always striving you're pushing
people you're you know there's always
more work to be done you're always at
the one percent in your pro in your
projects but on the other hand
um it's also for many a deferral of
their happiness and contentment off into
the future somewhere that will keep
moving as they move yeah off into the
distance yep how where is The Sweet Spot
between knowing there's more work to be
done but also being content at the
moment yes I love this a I think for me
it is this ever evolving daily practice
that I never quite get right but I'm
always playing with
these days it's about recognizing that
you know what I have created so much I'm
so proud of what I have and I'm a human
that is entrepreneurial and
multi-passionate and creative so there's
all these things it's the joy of going
like oh my goodness I'm so grateful for
what I have and here are the things that
I am so excited to create and for me it
becomes this really beautiful Dynamic
sense of being where I am fully joyful
and grateful for exactly what's
happening and super excited for what I'm
creating next so in the past it was like
oh well this isn't good enough I'm not
good enough I don't have you know it was
coming from a place of lack where these
days I'm coming from a place of
contentment and then an additional place
of curiosity and excitement about what's
unfolding next does that make sense yeah
of course it does yeah how many people
do you think you've coached over the
last
oh my goodness I think that would depend
on your definition of coached so we've
we've had over 100 million people
interact with our our videos and given
advice you've heard your advice or your
words
was there a moment when you realized
that this is what you wanted to do with
your life yes because I know you went to
Wall Street longer than you oh my
goodness I failed at so many jobs so
um I remember when I was on Wall Street
on the New York Stock Exchange I was
really excited about it because it was
this place where there was tremendous
potential for income right and I was
around people that were making millions
of dollars a year which is so far beyond
anything I could have imagined in my
life at that time and I was I kept
hearing this little voice inside Stephen
I was like this isn't who you are this
isn't what you're meant to do this isn't
who you're supposed to be and that
little voice kept getting louder and
louder but the little voice didn't tell
me what else I was supposed to do and
one day I was crying my eyes out because
I felt like such a failure my parents
had busted their buns to help me get
through college first in my family to go
to school and I knew that I was so lucky
to have that job just any job right
Healthcare a steady paycheck and here I
was miserable I wanted to quit so bad
and I just felt trapped because I didn't
want to bring shame upon my family I
felt like a total failure and the little
voice then said call your dad so I took
out my flip phone at the time which
gives you an idea it was like the lay
late 90s and I was crying to my dad and
I said Dad I'm so sorry like you and Mom
worked so hard to get me through school
and and I just I can't stand this job I
want to quit and he broke in all my
sniffly snotty crying and he's like Ray
he's like calm down he's like if this
job is getting you this sick and you
hate it you have to quit I said but Dad
I don't know what I'm supposed to do
like this isn't like me and he said look
you're going to work for the next 40 or
50 years of your life you have got to
find something you love and if this job
isn't it then start bartending do
whatever you need to do again but don't
stop looking until you find something
that you really really want to go to do
every single day
so the only things I knew about myself
were that I loved business but I was
also highly creative and the only com
combination that felt like it could work
in an industry was magazine publishing
at the time that was still a thing and I
went to a temp agency I got a job at
Gourmet magazine but about six months
into that job which was interesting I
started hearing that same voice against
Stephen I was like Ugh this isn't who
you are this isn't what you're supposed
to do this isn't what you're supposed to
be so I'm on the internet one day at
work probably when I shouldn't have been
and I stumbled upon this new profession
at the time called coaching
when I read this article it was as
though something in my soul lit up like
a Christmas tree it was like the clouds
parted and little angels came out and I
was like oh like this is what you're
supposed to do and I said I'm gonna do
this life coaching business and I went
back to bartending and waiting tables
and just devoted myself to figuring out
how to build a business during the day
okay so let's go back through so the
voice inside yes what is that voice
to me I believe it is my intuition
it is my when I say higher self I
believe the part of me that is timeless
that's probably been here before and
that will be here Beyond this particular
incarnation
and if anyone out there I certainly do
believes in a higher power that there
are other levels of intelligence that
are actually supportive of us that's who
I think that voice is does everyone have
that voice I absolutely believe so
that's my personal belief everyone has
that voice they may not have been
trained
to articulate and understand and discern
it but I believe it's there what does it
feel and sound like
soft spoken
it feels as though you're having an
inner nudge towards something that may
not make sense to the outside world it
may be counter to all of the social
conditioning the familial conditioning
that you've been brought up with but it
is gentle it is encouraging and it is
persistent I thought you were going to
say persistent that's the last word I
was like because I I can I can relate
um
why is it that and it's funny because I
also agree that everyone has that voice
um because when I have conversations
with people they will often tell me who
they are and what they do yeah and then
this the second thing is they'll like
whip out their phone and be like and
I've got this art Instagram account and
I'm like all the other voices like
infiltrated the the Asylum and it's like
taking over a little bit like I love
doing I work in the city I work in
finance but check out my art over here
it's kind of like the whisper that yes
I'm like that is the voice that's the
thing inside you that's been
persistently working away at you it made
you at 2AM launched that Instagram
account
um but most people because of the
there's another voice at play which is
the external voice Society your mother
your parents your immigrant parents
telling you what work is Instagram
telling you what you should and
shouldn't be an R
um that other voice that external Voice
is so much stronger yeah it's so much
stronger and it's everywhere it's in all
of our friends it's in our parents it's
up down left right yes how does one go
about
taking the perceived quote-unquote risk
of tuning into the that voice that's
just Whispering yes oh I love this
question and I also love talking about
this because I think it is one of the
most powerful sources of wisdom that we
all have but there are so many things
that we can talk about I want to talk
about a few one is if you start to pay
attention to the small things so I'll
give you an example
I've actually been practicing this is
going to sound extremely superficial but
stick with me intuitive shopping I don't
like to own a lot of things I'm just not
a person who likes a lot of clutter and
I just don't want to have a bunch of
crap lying around and so I realize that
sometimes I'm like oh well so and so if
I try on an outfit or whatever I'm like
oh I think this looks pretty good and
I've been paying attention to like nope
you're never gonna wear it it sounds so
silly but when I quiet down and I listen
I'm like okay I have this little
guidance for these little moments of my
day on the best path to take I want
people to pay attention to the small
moments what you should order on a menu
whether or not you should make a move
with your partner if people actually
look back in time and start to look in
their past you'll see places where you
heard that little voice and you overrode
it and you got yourself into trouble
do you know those times of course so
everyone has usually if you start to
filter through your mind it could have
been a financial decision it could have
been a business decision it could have
been about someone to hire it could have
about saying yes to a job a relationship
but there were times when something in
you was piping up and your ego or an
external voice was like no you got to go
for this this is a great deal this is
going to get you X Y and Z you should
say yes to this and you overwrote that
little voice and it cost you big time so
I think to answer the question how do
people start to kind of hone into that
discernment I think look in your past to
where you ignored it before and you'll
have examples of like oh that's what it
sounds like that's what it feels like
that's one and then I think number two
this works for me I'm someone who has
ADHD so I can have a very overactive
brain I need to meditate and I need to
exercise those are two things that help
me dial down the noise so much of the
static and create enough space for that
inner voice to not only feel like for me
to be able to detect it more but for it
to speak louder and for me to hear it
one of the things that sometimes
encourages us or
wins in US overriding The Voice
that small Whispering inside you telling
you who you are what you should be doing
where you should be what you're capable
of is our own like fear insecurities and
Trauma so like I can think of multiple
times where I've made bad decisions
because I've been LED too much by my
insecurities you know whether it's money
decisions whether it's love decisions
typically anything that's like psycho
psychological in its root so money food
these kinds of things so you might know
and even in the context of a
professional career
having the upbringing that you've had
where you made that Association super
early that money results in a loss of
Love or the lack of money results in a
loss of Love or a loss of control or
whatever that can orientate you to go to
Wall Street yes as opposed to listening
to The Voice yep how much do we have to
like heal in order to to kind of turn up
the volume of that voice inside and to
try and turn down the external voice you
know it's a great question I think we're
all on a healing Journey constantly
because I think all of us you know we've
kind of collected little hurts
disappointments
um things from our childhood things from
our adult experiences that kind of get
lodged in there I don't necessarily know
that intuition
requires like hearing your intuition
requires you to heal anything because I
think that voice is always trying to
talk to you and I think one of the best
ways to understand it's your intuition
and not fear and we should maybe talk
about that a little bit that's a I can
give people a very simple exercise about
how to know is this my intuition
speaking up saying no you know like you
shouldn't go in this direction or is
this just fear because I want to stay
safe and I don't want to put my ass on
the line
here's how I tell it so let's say I'm
thinking about saying yes to a
particular opportunity it could be a
business deal it could be you know
speaking at a particular event anything
like that
When I close my eyes and just feel in my
body and say does the idea of saying yes
to this make me feel expansive or
contracted and Stephen when I ask that
question in a nanosecond I say okay does
saying yes to the speaking engagement
feel expansive or contracted I guarantee
in your body you feel something it is so
subtle but either there is a lightness
there is like your body starts to expand
like this you lean forward there could
be a little bit of Joy even if you're
scared shitless even if saying yes to
this is like oh my goodness it's the
biggest opportunity ever or your ego
wants to say yes but inside there's a
part of you that says no it closes down
you feel heavy you feel a sense of dread
that's your intuition trying to lead you
in the right direction question yes do
you ever do things that are contractive
in feeling oh my gosh not as much
anymore but I did it so often earlier on
my journey because I was so desperate
for approval people and I was so
desperate to be successful and I had
these ideas if I partner with this
person if I say yes to this particular
activity if I show up here then I'm
gonna have some kind of more stature
right or I'm gonna be noticed more so
these days it happens much less
frequently and I feel like that just
comes from having skinned my knees
enough and tortured myself enough and
created enough pain and Chaos that I'm
like I don't need to do that anymore
yeah because a lot of the time the
reason I asked that particular question
is a lot of time a lot of the time
there's a short term
carrot I think that's the analogy for
yes it's a short-term carrot which goes
listen we'll give you this if you come
and do this thing you don't know if I
can do it but the short-term carrot can
be tempting sometimes the long-term
effects of taking a short-term carrot
are dangerous the other question I had
which was thinking about this expansive
contractive thing is there has been
times where something has made me feel
contractive yep but when then I've gone
and done it
oh my God you're so glad that you did so
glad I did it I'm curious when you felt
contracted and then you overrode that
can you tell me more about whether it
was the voice like what made you
override that feeling
um money interesting you're going to get
paid loads of money to go and do this
thing I think oh [ __ ] I don't want to
travel yeah I don't want to go there and
do it but then you go there and you have
a great conversation for example if I'm
speaking somewhere sure and I and it
lights me up that's what lights me up
yes so I walk away from it feeling
unbelievable thanks I'm so happy I did
that that's really you know it's changed
my mood It's Made Me connect with people
I'm so happy I did that yeah
um but ahead of time you know it's funny
because it's the story I'm telling
myself ahead of time that's making me
feel contractive it's I'm telling myself
about travel about time Wasted by having
to go to another country or city or
place I'm thinking about all the time
wasted okay and the money for me Isn't a
real big motivator but it almost for me
it's like it's still hard to turn down a
big number sure because the money
doesn't come to me it supports the team
it supports this podcast it supports our
show we have we this in my personal team
we have 25 20 people now yeah so a lot
of livelihoods I think of it as a
response ability yes so let's play here
for a moment because I think that's so
interesting what you shared a lot of
what you felt dread about was thoughts I
wonder and this would be fun maybe you
can text me and let me know in the
future I'm curious more of a body
sensation right right so like you I can
be like oh boy got some travel coming up
and my thoughts can generate a sense of
tiredness let's say but what I'm when
I'm talking about expansive and
contracted I'm actually talking more
about a physical sensation in your body
almost like either in your solar plexus
or in your gut so it's less of a thought
generated feeling and more of a visceral
full body notion does that distinction
yeah yeah just I'm I'm super curious
because I agree with what you've said in
terms of there's been times where I'm
like oh I don't know about this and I
was so and I got over myself I was like
you know what there's X Y and Z people I
like them there I'm gonna go see them
and I was so happy that that I wasn't a
stick in the mud and stayed home so I
had that experience too I'm
I want to dive a little deeper with you
on that body sensation because in my
experience that's usually where the
intuitive feeling kind of really lives
less thought generated more body more
body truth the body holds the school
yeah yeah so let's go back through then
so we're talking about this journey that
led you to leave the publishing industry
yes and decide to go back to being a
waitress but also pursuing the career of
being a coach yes a couple of key things
there that are that we kind of glossed
over that are I know people are sat at
home thinking they're in jobs they hate
they're in situations they hate they
hear the voice they get it
the next part I guess there's two parts
there the next part is
how do I how do I
tune into the voice and and like how do
I
um
you were lucky in the sense that you
read that article yes I say lucky but
maybe that's not the best use of words
you have you read that article that came
to you at that time that's right maybe
the universe sent it to you the
Journey's out right
if I know I'm in the wrong place and the
voice is saying [ __ ] Steve this magazine
publishing is not right yeah but I don't
know where the right place is how does
one go about finding that right place
okay I love this question so here's a
mantra and I live my life by Montrose
they help keep me on track and here's
one that really works Clarity comes from
engagement not thought Clarity comes
from engagement not thought what does
that mean in this context it means that
every single person listening right now
let's say they have a job and they're
like I am done with this job but I don't
know what else I should be doing there's
something in them that has an interest
it could be an interest in art it could
be an interest in baking it could be an
interest in music find a way to go take
action in that direction no matter what
it is it could be interning for someone
working for them for free picking up a
book taking a class finding some way to
get involved in that area will give you
not only Insight but it'll start to open
up creative channels you'll start to
meet people you'll start are to say oh
this is great as a hobby but I would
never want to do this as a career I
think that all of the Insight Clarity
comes from engagement not thought you're
not going to figure it out sitting on
your couch you're not going to figure it
out necessarily scrolling on Instagram
or your phone you're gonna figure it out
by getting into some kind of action and
giving yourself permission to experiment
right giving yourself permission to try
things and it might not work and that's
okay but you're going to learn something
you're going to discover something
you're going to have a conversation
you'll stumble upon your own article
where your own body lights up like a
Christmas tree and you'll be like oh my
goodness this is the thing but it's not
going to come if you sit at your desk
every day know that your work isn't
right but you don't do anything active
to actually go find out what is but you
know I'm busy I've got four kids I've
got a job I just don't have the time
right oh that's uh not having the time
is probably one of the biggest excuses
that we can all use from time to time
and it really is an excuse because all
of us know when it's important enough we
make the time if not we make an excuse
we know this if you're spending any
amount of time on Instagram or tick tock
on social if you listen to podcasts if
you do anything outside of your actual
job and just feeding yourself and doing
what you knew what you need to do to
stay alive you have time you really do
you have to do some basic math I would
recommend we talk about this in the book
is track your time meticulously for
seven days you will be shocked at how
much time flitters away doing things
that don't really create a ton of value
for you that don't give you an
opportunity to even have open time where
you're not looking you're not consuming
anything where you're not having other
people's thoughts ideas or agendas
inject into your head where you're just
giving yourself time to walk around the
outside and take a walk in the block and
in nature and actually let your mind
think or wonder or rest or exercise or
do any of these other things that can
open creative channels where you'll get
a download and you'll get an idea of
like oh my God I would have never
thought of that if your face was stuck
in Netflix or Hulu or Tick Tock for you
know the seven hours a day that you're
not working fine I'm quitting my job I'm
quitting quitting is difficult yeah
what's scary why is it so how do we
become
better quitters I was on stage this
morning I sat on stage and I said it all
the time so it's like I sound like a
broken record but you know we glamorized
starting it's like oh my God they
started this thing but quitting is the
equally important thing you have to do
before you start yes and so quitting is
just as much of a skill as starting
anything how do I become a better
quitter I look at your journey continue
quitting yeah throughout and it's funny
because that almost sounds like an
insult doesn't it no yeah but it does on
the surface because quitting is for
losers yes well if you believe that
that's the that's the slogan right but
if you hadn't quit imagine the the
misery I would have been so miserable
and so I think there's a couple of
things to it one I think understanding
your risk averseness as a human being is
very important and let me tell you what
that means for me financially speaking
I'm fairly risk averse so because of my
upbringing because of this kind of
Perpetual Financial scarcity that there
was I'm not the kind of person who's
just going to burn the ships behind me
and say okay I'm quitting my job you
know at the magazines and let me just
start this coaching business and figure
it out it was like no I went back to
bartending and waiting tables pretty
much seven days a week because that's
what it took to keep the roof over my
head and eating food while I figured out
this life coaching business so I would
say for anyone listening right now if
you're thinking about quitting take a
look inside what's your risk averseness
you know there's a study that was done
in the United States they tracked about
14 000 entrepreneurs and they found that
those who kept their day job as they
started their business were 33 percent
less likely to fail
and so I think for anyone listening it's
like okay well you may quit this job but
is there any other circumstance whether
you take another type of job you go
part-time like what is going to be the
kind of financial Runway or situation
that you need to give yourself an
ability to see if this business could
work if starting a business is what you
want to do
and and so after you quit
um seven years
doing side work yes and growing and
figuring out the business
when you quit what was your aspirations
for your coaching business if I'd ask
you on that day I'm going to say you
know how long ago was that so that was
two thousand like 2000 2001. right so
that's 20 odd years ago if I'd asked you
on that day
where are you going to end up oh my
goodness I had no freaking clue I at
that moment I was just entrenched in my
coach training and I wanted to be a
great coach so badly meaning I didn't
really have a huge Vision because
everything was so new and I think there
was so much uncertainty and quite
frankly as a 23 24 year old I didn't
really have the ability to have Vision
like I read so many success books
Stephen that were like you know and this
was like kind of a line in many of the
networking talks I'd go to it's like
well what's your five-year Vision right
I was like I have no idea I'm literally
trying to just get the next three paying
clients like I will Coach your dog if
you let me I will Coach that's where I
was because I was so committed to trying
to be the best coach I could be and I
knew that I needed experience I needed
to work with as many people as possible
so I had no vision for where this thing
would go I just kept taking the next
step and the next step and the next step
and kind doing this it's not talked
about enough what you've just said
because perfectionism is one of the
things that causes procrastination and
especially as we set out to quit and
start the new thing you hear it all the
time I know you do which is well I
haven't got enough of this and I haven't
figured out this and I need to find a
mentor and an investor and this and a
website name and this and that whereas
in reality in everything I've ever done
it's this like horrifically messy
stumbling forward in into the darkness
like and even with this podcast like
I'll tell you how it came to be was I
enjoyed doing it that was it that was
the thesis didn't know how we'd make
money didn't know how big it would get
didn't know if other people would like
it actually still blown away that anyone
listens because it's like it's been one
of the most amazing like life-affirming
things that people care about the types
of conversations we have here yes but I
think that's such an important message
because perfectionism as you write about
in the book you talk about progress and
perfectionism and which one to choose
it's such a it's such an imprisoning
notion that is so pumped up by like fake
life coaches and fake entrepreneurs that
want to try and sell you something to
make them by making themselves seem like
they are super special and God gifted
yes we're all just messy little
unorganized scared
um 100
and so human and so this is the other
thing like so start before you're ready
so Stephen I have to tell like as a
young life coach I knew how ridiculous
it all sounded it sounded cheesy to me
again can I tell you my first Workshop
there was five people in it I was 24.
that's a lot my parents
my yoga instructor from college and
um one of her neighbors actually two of
her neighbors that she pulled in off of
the street and I had created a whole
little workbook I had done it with like
Microsoft clip art I stapled the little
workbooks together and I stood in front
of five people in my yoga teachers
basement in New Jersey and I delivered
like a day-long workshop and like I
think back to that cringy Marie but she
was also awesome because she started
before she was ready she didn't know
what the hell was going on but she did
it and it was like the worst thing I
probably ever did but I did it and then
it gave me a little bit of experience to
then like go do something else and then
go do something else so to your point
it's like everything for me has been
messy I'm like I don't know if this is
gonna work this sounds like a lot of fun
I have energy towards it I want to make
a difference let's try it
and what about today as you sit here now
yeah
um today it's still messy I've talked
about this all the time I'm like you
know 99 of what any of us need to do to
grow our business we've never done
before so we don't know what the hell
we're doing that's why for me everything
is figureoutable this phrase is so
useful like I use it every day still
it's not like there's some blueprint or
some road map to guaranteed success out
there like that's not how it works and
if you're someone who's Innovative or
creative or you're trying to do
something outside of the box there
certainly ain't no Playbook so you have
to be willing to just try things and
experiment and flop around and laugh at
yourself and then get up the next day
and do it again in the book you talk
about these the three points of
philosophy that oh the three rules the
three rules yeah the underpin this
figure outable
mindset yes what are those so rule
number one is that all problems or
dreams are figureoutable rule number two
if a problem or a dream isn't figure
outable it's a law of nature right so
death maybe taxes rule number three you
may not care enough to solve a
particular dream or reach a particular
goal and that's okay find something that
you do care deeply about and go back to
rule number one and what that does is it
creates a container
a container for us as human beings to be
honest about what we care enough about
to go figure it out because in in my
life there hasn't been one thing yet
that I have truly wanted to either
understand achieve transform do you know
what I have some different relationship
with that when it was true in my heart
that I haven't been able to figure it
out and if I don't want to figure
something out like I can get real at
myself like I don't care enough about
this to go figure it out right now
that's super important yes number three
it's the one we don't talk about yeah
because we'll all have goals in our life
that we
we think are important we think we want
to do I want to you know I want to
become a DJ I want to start working out
and get a six-pack I want to be an
artist
they they often don't happen and we we
end up thinking that they haven't
happened because we are an unmotivated
person so we say you know we start being
ourselves up I'm not motivate I'm a
failure I'll just keep trying at it we
very rarely pause and go do I actually
want to and there's this weird thing
that I that I noticed which I won't name
the person but they know who they are
because I know they're listening there's
this weird thing that I observed which
taught me a really important lesson is
sometimes like we want to want something
and the way we're just laughing the way
that I describe that is like
we want to want something we want to
have the motivation to do the thing we
want to want it yeah we want to want it
we think we should want it yes so we so
we go around saying we want it so like I
wanna I really want to go and lift
weights I might say Stephen I really
want you know I I'm saying to the world
you know I really want to go and lift
weights but it's because I want to be
the type of person that wants to be that
that wants that yes so I go around
saying it but I don't actually want it I
just want to want it yes I had this same
conversation with my best friend and we
were laughing about this because I have
put so much pressure on myself at so
many different points of my career
because I think I should want something
yeah and I'm like but if I okay for
example I think you'll appreciate this
because I think you and I share a
similar philosophy perhaps um about
social media for example
so I suck at social media right I'm
never on it I don't put any attention
and I actually had a colleague of mine
say to me like Marie you're so good at
what you do like why aren't your numbers
bigger and it was like one of these you
know like when someone makes a comment
you're like oh that kind of feels like a
punch in the gut and you're just like oh
oh I I don't know and anyone who knows
me my friends and even my audience they
know I'm like very transparent like I
don't spend a lot of time on my phone
like I'd prefer to write books I create
programs like there's other things and
then I I just want to live my life like
I feel like I'm like oh there's like oh
if I was really committed to being a
change maker then I would be making
videos I was like what the hell is that
philosophy like I remember torturing
myself I should want to want that
exactly but the truth is I don't exactly
and that's the hard part to admit yes
yes it's a really hard part to admit
that we just don't care enough we just
don't want it it's someone else's it's
someone else's and I think that just
having this conversation because I would
imagine there's folks listening to us
right right now that think that they
should want to want something and they
don't and then what happens so you know
I failed to go to the gym to get that
six-pack that I I tell myself I want or
I failed to start that business because
I don't really want to but I want to
want to start it yeah and then I use
excuses I and the the number one excuse
is I just don't I don't have the time
because that's a cloaking of as you said
earlier that's a cloaking of your true
priorities yep it's a way of saying so
it's not my fault it's just a lack of uh
time in the day there's only 24 hours
but really as you've said it's actually
that the how you use your time as one of
the clearest demonstrations of your
actual priorities of your values yeah
100 100 the the way that I always like
to keep myself honest about like what I
want and to call myself out on my own
excuses this is the the two-word
distinction that has helped me the most
understanding the difference between
can't versus won't so any time that I'm
about to say oh I can't do that I can't
do this I can't get up earlier to work
out to get those six packs I can't can't
write my next book I just don't have the
time for me learning Italian I can't
learn Italian I have so much on my plate
right now with my business so 99 not 100
99 of the time when we human beings say
can't it's a euphemism firm won't and
what does won't mean won't means we
really don't want to we're not willing
to make the sacrifice it's not that
important to us right now and so I
always encourage myself and other people
to play with this like any time you're
about to say the word can't try on won't
or try on that's not a priority for me
right now and see how your body feels
going back to this body truth something
of me goes you know what I actually
don't want to learn Italian right now
you know why because in my free time I'm
watching the house of dragons I do you
know what I mean I'm watching this show
or that show or I'm hanging out with my
friends or I'm doing this I'm doing
something else where I could be
dedicating that to my Italian Studies
but I'm not you know why because that is
not my priority right now that is so so
much more honest and it's so much more
freeing and then all of a sudden I'm not
a bad person I'm not not ambitious
enough I'm just me it's so it's so such
a small important change in like words
and and thinking just that swap swap
from I can't do something which says
it's not possible right or I'm not in
control which is even the worst one I
can't it's not not possible to I won't
which empowers you in such an important
way it says actually these are decisions
that I'm making I'm not the puppet I'm
the puppet master of my life that's
right and I get to call the shots around
here that's right and it says I and I
think just like that's not my priority
right now I choose not to that's not my
choice at this it's not much better you
can try on any one of those but all of a
sudden like something in you I think
feels the honesty you feel the alignment
all of us you feel more alive and you
have more energy and I'll tell you you
do that enough you tell yourself the
truth about you enough and all of a
sudden you start falling in love with
the real you
not the you that you think you're
supposed to be to get everyone else to
like you not the you that Society has
told you that you have to be or all the
people that you compare yourself to who
are probably faking it anyway but you
fall in love with the real you and
that's in my experience where real
happiness and satisfaction and
fulfillment comes from
the other part of that that switching
from
I can't to I won't is in the external
relationships we have with others
because I made the mistake with my
partner once upon a time of when she
suggested something to me and I did not
want to do it I would say I can't right
what I'm doing is I'm absolutely lying
to her because she you know she she
wants to go and do this thing at this
place and I guess I can't because I
pointed my schedule I guess you know
what I'm doing is I'm is I'm telling her
I want to so ask me again in the future
because I'm interested
but I can't right now because of an
external Factor so my girlfriend keeps
asking me if I want to do this thing and
I'm continuing to continue to say I
can't and it's building a really
inauthentic relationship well that's
fundamentally built on a set of Lies
there was a point and I think it was
because one of my podcast guests where I
just tried being honest yeah and it was
the best thing I've ever done yeah and
you know what she really appreciated it
because I don't want to do that it's so
important even you know in business and
in relationships and all of those things
someone being honest with you is very
rare that it's so effective when they
are I actually took a phone call as I
was coming down the stairs to start this
conversation from someone and they
called me and said
hi Stephen just so you know this is a
cold call so if you if you um don't want
to do the chord just hang up now but if
you've got 20 seconds let me know
and I was shocked
absolutely shocked the guy probably I
think he told me he listened and I said
to him what a [ __ ] that's brilliant
because usually I'm like I spend 10
seconds trying to figure out if they're
trying to sell me something so I can
just crack on with my day but for him to
be so honest with me by the way he
literally this is a cold call I'm going
to tell you about a product if you don't
want to take the call feel free to hang
up now and I was like this is amazing
what is it he told me I went on their
website I looked it up I said we use a
different tool called brandwatch so but
I said like this has been so inspiring
your honesty with me that it was so
disarming yeah and I think people are
smarter than we give them credit for so
what's what's happened on every cold
call that I've ever received is that you
know they call Mingo hi Steve is it
Stephen Bartlett I go who is it I think
it was the Stephen Butler I go who is it
the game just want to check is it
Stephen Bartlett I go yeah they go
so what are you doing with your data
infrastructure things at the moment
because we've got an offering and it's
like and then I'm like [ __ ] get out of
there but it's but the honesty was so
disarming and people are smarter than we
give them credit for so when you go
around telling your friends or your
loved ones whatever or your work
colleagues that you can they know yes
they know yeah but you don't want to
totally so something I want to think you
talked about we talked about
relationships though a topic we haven't
touched on completely it's funny I know
you wrote a book in 2000 and I'm gonna
say eight that's when it was published
yeah the earliest version was actually
like 2002 it was a eBook that was full
of hot pink and a lot of exclamation
points
that tells me everything about how you
feel about the book today yeah I a I
still stand behind the book today but I
was just it's also an explanation of how
things evolve yeah right
what's your journey been like with
romantic love oh my goodness so
um challenging like most people one of
my biggest challenges was actually I've
known from a very very young age that I
basically never wanted to be married or
have children
so that was just like it was this inner
knowing
you know many young girls at least my
friends they would fantasize about like
my wedding day and you know there was
lots of dolls and okay this is my baby
and all that stuff and I just never had
any of those desires or inklings and as
I became a teenager like why do you
think do you know I don't know besides I
know it's my truth and I have never
wavered on it could it be related to
your parents relationship at all it
could it very well could prior to Josh I
would meet folks and and and be in
relationship and they'd be like okay so
we're gonna get married then we're gonna
have kids and I'm like are you actually
listening because that's not what this
thing wants so that's that is not the
path I'm on so it was actually really
really challenging
um until I until Josh and I got together
back in 2003 and I felt like I had found
my soul mate how much have you thought
about how your early experiences have
like impacted your attachment style when
I look at some of my friends and the
relationships they have they often seem
to mirror the model they learn in their
household yeah so I've actually gone so
a couple things this has been an area of
Fascination for me mostly because a I
just want to be a really good partner
and a good human and especially with
Josh like we've had so many ups and
downs oh my God Stephen we've done so
much therapy and and I'm gonna share
something I don't know if you have
interviewed these this couple yet or
you're familiar with their work but
these folks in my opinion they were the
game changers and it does relate to kind
of early childhood Impressions and how
we were brought up and how that impacts
how you interact in your adult
relationships so um the most
game-changing
work that I've ever done when it comes
to having a healthy relationship is from
Harvel Hendricks and Helen lekelly Hunt
so there's a book called getting the
love you want it was like huge I think
in the 90s and then maybe the early
2000s I had never heard of it but Josh
and I stumbled upon it when honestly we
were on that we were in a really really
tough place and I didn't know if we were
going to make it through and
um
Josh had been talking with someone who
was like oh you guys should try Imago
therapy which is the kind of therapy
that they have developed this whole body
of work there's International therapists
they're friggin fantastic I was like we
must study with these people so they
kind of talk about the fact that every
single person
um you learn things in your family unit
so for me there was a lot of kind of
smothering that happened at certain
points so I need to be free I need to be
free and for Josh one of his kind of
core and they use this language and you
know it like a childhood wound for him
it was abandonment
so he wants to be close so oftentimes we
will pick the person that has the exact
opposite childhood wound so for me
someone that wants freedom of course is
going to choose a partner that wants
more attachment
so
in their work it's actually like you
choose the perfect partner to heal the
very things that you need to heal
so for me that you are saying okay do
you think that has to relate to just the
fact that I don't want to get married
just the fact that all that stuff does
that really it probably does because
there was a lot of me wanting to be free
in my childhood a lot of me feeling very
constricted and held back and so for
Joshua was the opposite but I would
highly recommend their work if you have
not explored it if anyone has not
explored it it totally saved us well
Josh you talk about the hard times in
um around 2017. it was we had several we
had um so when my stepson was leaving
for college I think this was around
maybe
2009 or 10. I might be getting the years
wrong forgive me but um I was basically
I was such a workaholic I was such a
workaholic and he was so just desirous
of just more attention and I was so
obsessed with my business and so
obsessed with trying to be successful
and this fear if I slowed down that
would all be taken away then this fear
that if I didn't continue to work and
build that I was going to lose
everything and it almost destroyed my
relationship it was terrible we had been
together I think oh I can probably do
the math better now so we'd been
together about six or seven years we met
in 2003 so it's probably about 2010 and
we had never once taken a proper
vacation together
because I always said that I couldn't
because I was too busy working
yeah
it's so funny
um I have a friend who is reminds me of
you so much in that way in the sense
that she has an immigrant story she came
to this country when she was super young
she was
um
bullied
in school she found some you know she
she found they didn't have any money
that was the source of much of the pain
in our home
she started a business starts to go well
she doesn't want to get married she
doesn't want to have kids her partner
has recently broken up with her because
her partner is not getting any time from
her and she just works all the time
I watch her and I think you're being
dragged by that fear of
going back to your childhood you're
being dragged by it or like like a
being tied to the back of a car that's
just flying down the motorway yes and I
just don't know what to say to her
because
she
She's suffering the consequences of not
having connections or friends or love in
her life yes but her ankle is attached
to the back of this Lorry and it is
flying down the motorway her business is
killing it when I say killing it I mean
she's probably worth hundreds of
millions she's super young she's in a
early she's in her 20s
um but she's unhappy but she can't get
off the [ __ ] Lorry it's dragging her
yeah would you say to someone like that
I think that it's really important for
every person to come to that realization
that
they may be killing it in certain areas
and then to be honest enough to say the
areas where it's not working and then I
would always come back to if you want
this it's kind of like we go back to
everything is figure outable if having
love in your life friendships in your
life Adventure in your life down time in
your life is important to you you can
absolutely figure it out and what I've
seen in my own journey and this is my
own personal estimation of myself I've
actually become way more successful I've
become a better Coach I've become a
better teacher I've become a better
friend I've become a better partner
not being dragged by my drive
not allowing
the fear of losing any success that I've
built
be the force that keeps me from the
richest parts of my life which are my
connections for anyone who's who's in
that space right now they have to want
to make that choice to change and then
be willing to as much as they took the
risk to start a business they have to be
even more courageous to redefine their
own success at a higher different level
and it takes courage takes a lot of
Courage so how did you redefine your own
definition of success at a high level so
for me it was around really stepping
back and asking myself what matters most
like is it the money in the bank account
is it the amount of followers or
customers or whatever and I remember
sitting in that therapy chair and like
thinking about what I've grown and then
seeing this beautiful man and going like
you know what it's not about choosing
either or but like you've got a problem
Marie and you got to fix this like this
thing meaning the business cannot be
your number one priority if you know in
your heart that love is the most
important thing in life then you need to
start demonstrating that you need to
start acting that you need to start
making time for that God you know in
your heart yeah so this is the
interesting thing because we all know
yeah like
objectively no because we've read read
that it's true we met you know I see
this a lot I see like we know we should
goes back to kind of the wanting to want
thing yeah I know that people are
happier when they have friends and when
they have a romantic partner typically
in whatever Dynamic that's that
relationship is formed I know that to be
true
but I feel like I need to keep building
this [ __ ] business and climbing that
ladder and sure it's such an intense
strong all-consuming feeling just to
keep on going keep throwing coal into
the engine of this train yep but I know
I should spend time with my friends this
is where I'm gonna go back well all this
stuff so as it relates and I think those
are maybe two different slight nuances
so I would go back to the Helen and the
Harville work like there's a couple of
tools that they teach you one of which
is this tool called dialogue it's a very
structured
form of having a conversation with your
loved one
Stephen I cannot tell you how healing
this particular form of work is you
could probably look it up online they do
tons of workshops very inexpensively
they're actually even taking their
workshops into police departments like
because it is transformative how it
helps people connect how it helps people
see each other how it helps people hear
each other and how it helps people heal
and when Josh and I started practicing
these tools that we learned from from
Harvel and Helen
something in me relaxed and I was able
to see and hear and recognize and
understand Josh's needs in a way that
did not feel threatening to my own drive
for my own success it was as if
previously those two things were at odds
and then all of a sudden everything was
integrated where he felt really heard
and seen and I felt really heard and
seen and it was as though that battle
completely disintegrated
and so no longer was it this or that no
longer was it will either give me
attention or you know what I mean I have
to give up this business no it was like
oh now I understand what he really needs
which is not tons of time it's actually
presence and giving him support and love
in the way that he can really feel it
and while he gets nurtured and it's
completely different than how I do but
again this is like a practice and it's
nothing that we're taught in school so
we're all just stumbling around at least
I was and Josh and I were and now it
feels like Josh is so much more
supportive of all the things I do in my
business and ironically not it's not
that I care less but I'm less driven by
fear it's more driven by desire and fun
and creativity and wouldn't it be cool
if oh let's try that and only saying yes
to things that are like a full body yes
not saying yes to things because I think
it's going to get me somewhere or it's
going to you know get that bag so much
bigger it's like you know what at some
point enough's enough I'm sure you've
experienced this it's like when does
enough become enough
quick word from one of our sponsors I've
got a tip for all of you that will make
your virtual meeting experiences I think
10 times better as some of you may know
by now Blue Jeans by Verizon offers
seamless high quality video conferencing
but the reason why I use blue jeans
versus other video conferencing tools is
because of immersion their tools make
you feel more connected to the employees
or customers you're trying to engage
with and now they're launching one of
their biggest feature enhancements to
impact virtual events so far called Blue
Jean Studio I actually used it the other
day I did a virtual event using the
studio which I think about 700 of you
came to TV level production quality all
done by one person with very little
technical experience on a laptop so if
you've got an event coming up and you're
thinking about doing it virtually check
out blue jean studio now let me know
what you think because I genuinely
believe I know this is an advert and I'm
supposed to say this but I genuinely
believe it's the best tool I've seen for
doing really immersive simple but high
quality production virtual events quick
one it's so crazy that in the last
couple of months I've had so many people
tag me on Instagram even on Telegram and
in my Twitter DMs in a picture of them
starting their heal journey and it's one
of the most amazing things in my life
that I get to do a podcast which of
course needs money to to fuel and I have
a sponsor like you who I genuinely
believe is going to help every single
person who starts their heel Journey
change their life because this podcast
the central intention of this podcast is
to help people live better lives and we
get to sit here and I get to promote to
you a product which has not only helped
me change my life but it's going to help
millions of people and is helping
millions of people live a nutritionally
complete life it's so it's such an
incredible product and for me the reason
why it's incredible is because it gives
me my protein it gives me my vitamins
minerals it's plant-based it's low in
sugar gluten free it does all of that in
a small drink that tastes good there are
other products there's Foods there's the
hot and savory collection many other
things but for me this ready to drink is
the absolute savior of my diet
throughout the week where I'm moving at
such Pace look I don't want to labor the
point but if you haven't tried he'll
give it a try and if you do tag me
Instagram wherever you try it give me a
tag anyway
back to the podcast
I did actually want to ask because
men don't often including me as a man we
don't often appreciate the social battle
that
and the social stigma and criticism that
women who say the things like I want to
focus on my career yeah yeah I don't
want to have kids I don't want to get
married sometimes undergo and I've I've
because I have these conversations now
I'm continually like cognizant of my own
bias in the way that I ask the questions
yeah
how do you view all of that like how do
you view the the pressure that women
face to fall in line with the
old school stereotype of kids they're in
such a changing world yeah you know it's
really interesting so one of the things
I do on my show marietv is I answer
questions I love just taking questions
from our audience and answering them and
one of our viewers said hey Marie how
did you decide not to have kids and we
had never covered the topic before and I
was like oh well let me just I want to
talk about that and it was one of the
most popular episodes that we haven't
we've ever had and it was because it
sparked this discussion just about
choice and about oh wow you just didn't
want them and you knew that it like
wasn't a struggle and I'm like that's
maybe not everyone's journey and that's
great but I need to be honest about mine
because one of the things and we've had
talks with my mom about this it's like
her kind of set prescription was so
there from society and from it's like
you get married and you have kids and
that was I think her authentic dream but
it was also the conditioning right and
um I just think it's interesting I like
talking about it because I think it's
really important for every woman to know
that she has the right to choose her
Destiny and whether that Destiny
includes a family doesn't include a
family includes some semblance of what
she believes as a family like I want
women to have that choice I can't tell
you how many comments were under that
video people left comments anonymously
who had given birth and absolutely loved
their kids and said I would have made a
different choice if I knew I had one
and it was shocking
how many women feel that they must
follow this prescription and I think in
2022 when we're recording this I'm like
you know my eyes bulge out of my head
I'm like no they don't have to and we
need everyone's gifts and it's like I
just knew from the moment that I could
understand I was like that is not my
path in this lifetime my path in this
lifetime is to help people give birth to
their ideas and to possibilities it's
not necessarily to give birth to a
physical child through my physical body
and so um I like to talk about it just
because I want women to have as many
choices as they possibly can to be as
brilliant and as impactful and happy as
they possibly can
yeah certainly not setting off a topic
we talk about enough yeah because it
goes back to these kind of like
colliding narratives The Narrative is
much stronger that
you know you get married at the stage
you do this you get a mortgage you get a
house you have your kids totally before
here if you don't you're a failure
that's right we all feel that men feel
it too in other ways but I think the the
social pressure sometimes is a little
bit more intense on women to meet these
deadlines in these timelines yeah
time genius yes before we started
talking I asked you what was front of
mind at the moment and you said time
genius yes why did you say that so uh
probably for I would say almost a year
and a half if not two years so much of
my own Creative Energy has been pouring
into this uh new program this new
experience that we created really born
out of my own pain I
hit a wall at the end of 2020 where I
didn't realize how burned out I was I
think like many of us and I found myself
in this position that I never found
myself in my whole career where I
started dreading waking up in the
morning and so I went on this journey of
discovering and putting together like
how do we heal the Paradigm of living in
time stress and I described that where
it's like you don't know what to focus
on first when you wake up in the morning
because there's so many things to do you
feel guilty if you take a rest for five
minutes because your brain says I should
be doing something more important you
have trouble prioritizing you feel like
no matter how many hours you put in It's
never enough so we put together this
program and it has honestly helped me so
much and then I shared it with my
audience I've never seen anything get
results for people it has changed
everything for me I went on um what is
it it's there's there's really five key
parts to it first it's about changing
our mindset from the inside out about
getting out of time stress and living as
a Time genius where you know in your
bones and in practice that there is
always time for what's most important
it's a complete different Paradigm again
we can talk more about it it's a little
bit too lengthy to get into everything
here the second part of it is when you
know it's important you can ignore
what's not I found that for me in
different parts of my life and I'm
pretty good at this one but I can I'm
always practicing is if there's too much
on my plate if everything's important
nothing's important and then all of a
sudden I'm working all the time I've got
17 plates in the air but when I have one
project one primary project and
everything else is kind of secondary my
life has spaciousness I have Focus
beautiful work gets done like it's just
a different way to operate and you have
such an easier time saying no to things
when you know exactly what's important
at this stage and season of your life
then there's the third step is really
about setting yourself up to win every
single day and we're all different in
this way so if you think about you know
do you like having a messy desk or a
clean desk
somewhere in the middle well I like
having a clean desk but my desk is
always messy but so you probably operate
pretty well through there like it's
comfortable for you I've survived thus
far yeah yeah yeah but some people are
like I know people that are minimalist
and you know it's like I love having my
books around me I love having notebooks
around me but a lot of people don't make
an ecosystem or design their environment
to really help them Thrive and then of
course there's certain things we can do
with technology to make sure we're never
interrupted that distractions don't
happen different things we can do with
our brain
um and then it's a lot about kind of
setting yourself up for follow-through
and not relying on motivation which as
you know the silliest thing to rely on
on Earth so that's kind of like the
brief overview of it but as I've been
walking people through this program and
seeing how fast they get results it just
makes me happy because folks are they're
lowering their stress levels they're
having time to be with their kids
they're taking walks on the beach
they're getting more done in less time
and they're not feeling exhausted
anymore and so it's a really rewarding
thing one of the words I wrote down is
you're talking
multi-passionate yes yes
you said you had ADHD yeah
is that somewhat linked to
your multi-passionate entrepreneurialism
it's it's a great question that I don't
know if I have a good answer to
um because I'm certainly not a clinical
psychologist like I went to um the best
ADHD doctor in the country who gave me
the diagnosis and he's like you have the
gift I'm like thank you I have the gift
thank you very much so I don't know if
those two things are linked
um but what I do know is anytime that
I've shared that phrase with many people
they're like oh my gosh I think I'm
multi-passionate too it's the person
that has this beautiful business and has
that art Instagram account and is an
amazing Chef too and it just gives us
again it's a silly little phrase that
just kind of gives you a little bit of a
playground to talk about your different
interests and maybe a way that doesn't
make you feel as broken as I did what is
focus sit within that because that when
people hear that they think of a lack of
focus yeah which is the as you say the
antithesis of like entrepreneurial
advice it's like focus on something do
it for 10 is be consistent Focus so I
tried that that approach because I read
about it so much and I'm like oh my gosh
I must follow what everyone says because
that's the path to success and Stephen
when I tried to just be a coach and just
do like the bartending on the side to
earn money I felt like I was cutting off
a limb there were so many other pieces
of me that were screaming to be
expressed and I was like what's wrong
with me why can't I just be a coach and
be happy and then do my bartending like
why can't it be that simple but I was
probably um 23 or 24 and I love dance I
was not a trained dancer it was just
something that was in my body and in my
soul and I sat down with myself and I
did something called the 10-year test
this is something that has served me
well too
I thought I said okay Marie
if when you're 34 and you look back and
you did not at least try to make dance a
part of your career will you regret it
and the answer was hell yes so when I
was 24 even though I didn't have any
dance training and it was just a passion
I started taking more dance classes and
I started teaching Fitness classes which
got me into a whole world of eventually
becoming a Nike dance athlete but the
point of that is I tried to follow that
path of one thing and I just failed
miserably and because I was so unhappy I
said all right [ __ ] it I'm gonna pursue
Dance I'm gonna pursue coaching I'm
gonna do the bartending I'm going to let
all of my different interests Thrive
knowing that I couldn't do that forever
I knew I wouldn't earn as much money as
a coach I knew I was going to kind of
keep everything a little bit slower
because my focus would be split but the
joy and the Fulfillment that came from
giving myself permission to pursue all
these different things far outweighed
any slowness of growth or financial gain
I think that's the I think that's it I
think um I was thinking about it as
you're speaking and
the Trap there or the typically it will
you know we get ourselves in really
complicated positions in life because
words a single word like find your
passion it's a singular word yes so
within the fact that there's an S
missing on the end of it
sends you a message that there should be
one it's an Easter egg and you need to
go and search for it you can you have to
go and find it you know all these words
can [ __ ] us up sometimes in life and one
of the words that I think [ __ ] people
up when they're thinking about what you
just said is
I think at the start of you said
something like I know I wouldn't be as
successful yes because of the the
definition we're using for success in
that case is not happiness you just
ended up saying like I was way more
fulfilled and way more but I wouldn't
make as much money so if you if I'm
saying like if you're if your definition
of success had always been happiness
then
and if that was your guiding your North
Star then of course you'd become a
multi-passionate entrepreneur but if
your definition of success which nobody
says it's just making shitloads of money
and ignoring all the sort of branches of
expression that we all have and all of
Interest we have then of course you
would have probably focused on coaching
you might have been a bigger coach as
you said like you might have been you
know whatever not that you you didn't
get there anyway but because you did but
you know it might have been faster let's
say yeah but I think it would and the my
counter to that was this so all of that
experience like teaching with Nike and
also being on camera like in some weird
targets and and Walmarts in the states
like there's actual DVDs of me on
Fitness videos back when there was like
this and like you know what I mean
because but all of that experience set
me up to start my own YouTube show set
me and it brought all of these different
expressions and
influences into my brand that lived
today that make it very very different
than other people you know there's some
people that are coaches that are
brilliant and they have this beautiful
academic background or different things
and for me all of that flavor made its
way in and it gave me the confidence and
and I think a uniqueness that um
actually made the business that I have
today so much more rich and so much more
unique unique and um and joyful to run
that's exactly what creativity is isn't
it it's having
um
rare and uh unique points of inspiration
and experience and bringing them
together to create something new so like
you know you're doing Fitness stuff yes
one can see how the lessons you learned
there
are still in the work you do today and
the example as I look down at this iPad
in front of me that I that I always talk
about when I'm talking about how like
straight seemingly strange things can
end up defining you seemingly strange
creative Inspirations can Define you as
is the iPad and apple and knowing that
Steve Jobs taking that typography class
was ultimately the reason much of the
reason why apple is they care so much
about design and Detail in typography
and that set them apart from other
brands which I won't name and you'd
never think that would make sense and
but he cites that in his commencement
speech he cites these really obscure
classes he took as being the reason why
apple is what it is today but in typical
narrative we say to like if you want to
be a coach go do a course on how to be a
coach just that like right don't [ __ ]
music right which could be a great [ __ ]
breath work or this meditation class you
want to do [ __ ] all these other things
Focus yeah but the best those that
create really unique feeling stuff that
the world really has never seen or felt
before but needs are those that
pulling Inspirations from the most
bizarre Unthinkable places to create a
new coaching business that's right what
are you struggling with
now it's less of a struggle more of uh
this is what I'm playing with and I'm
I'm I'm excited about getting better at
you know I'm here to give a beautiful
talk in an event and it's something that
I haven't done a lot of because we've
been in covid and all this stuff and I
can get nervous on stage I can get
really nervous like I'm very very
comfortable with cameras and having
one-on-one conversations but I can get
super nervous on stage when it's not
like my people that have come to see me
so that's something that I've been
working on a lot this year what does
that mean in a like a detailed a
detailed practical sense that you're
that's the thing you're struggling with
is it so it's an anxiety a fear yeah
sometimes it's it's about oh my gosh you
know people will ask me to come speak on
stage different stages and and I've said
no so often because I have so many other
things that my attention's on and I'm a
person I I like to prepare and I like to
deliver as much value as I can I want to
take care of a host and Their audience
and like putting together I'm like oh
gosh what's the talk gonna be like I can
feel my mind going into a super swirly
place and it's not fun and it was like I
need to handle this I'm like I don't
need to handle this on my own you know
everything is figureoutable but that
doesn't mean that I can't ask for help
figuring it out so for me it's it's
about
um working through the anxiety and the
nerves around okay well how can I
construct the best talk how long should
it be the delivery how many stories like
a lot of kind of technical things it's
it might sound really silly I don't know
if it does or not but it's things that
like my head just goes like this about
and I'm like okay where does that come
from in you I don't know I think that um
one of the things I've seen about myself
is that when I do something enough times
I get super comfortable with it and then
I can be really creative and playful
and so I think it's honestly a lack of
having done it a lot recently like when
I was on book tour it was just like ah
like it was so much fun and it had like
a very clear Focus I was like oh we're
talking about the book and all the
content was right there but when things
are more free form I'm so creative that
it can get like wild and crazy so I want
to put containers around stuff and give
myself more opportunities to do it in a
way where it feels really fun
what about personally what are you
struggling with personally that was a
professional example okay personally
struggling
I don't and this is not I'm probably
gonna sound like a total [ __ ] so I'll
just say that out loud at this
particular moment I don't feel a sense
of struggle around something
consistently in my personal life like I
feel I spent so much time over the past
couple of years we're talking about the
time genius stuff like really taking
care of my mental health and really
starting to kind of unprogram and
reprogram some of the stuff that I've
tortured myself with in the past that I
finally feel such a level of peace and
acceptance of like who I am and Josh and
I have done so much work and I feel so
grateful and he's the person I spend the
most time with
and we have just such a I'm so grateful
for our relationship so in the personal
realm there's not one that comes up
right now that doesn't mean it's not
gonna come up with Josh yes if I'd
called him this morning and I said Josh
what does Marie struggle with personally
yeah what would he say he might oh I
know what he would say he would probably
say
um being hard on herself
being hard on herself like I like
basically before I was coming here and
getting I was like you think the Talk's
gonna go okay he's like it's gonna go
great like you know I can have those
like just like is it gonna all be okay
like that kind of stuff and um
yeah I think he's just like you he's
consistently my Champion for being nicer
to myself like if he catches me
sometimes I won't catch it myself if I'm
going into a mode of like really getting
focused and you know maybe working a
little too long is like have you eaten
I'm like thank you because I have not or
something like that are you still being
dragged
you know I don't feel that way
that that's the honest to goodness truth
we had a there was a couple of
opportunities that came up specifically
around this trip and I heard that you
should do that right I heard that voice
I was and I just politely declined and I
didn't feel any guilt about it I was
like it that felt new for me to be
honest because I've gone on trips and
work trips and things like that and like
every moment of every day you know what
I mean was packed so that you could
maximize every opportunity and before I
came here to see you like I was with my
team and like shopping for a pair of
jeans that I really wanted
and it was it was lovely
in them everything is figure outable in
chapter 10. yes
the world needs your special gift yes
that's what that's the name of the
chapter
um there's a quote you say most high
Achievers struggle with feeling like a
fake but never talk about it
it's like a dirty little secret
everyone's afraid to admit I'll tell you
right now
I still feel this way at times and I've
been doing this work for almost two
decades
do you feel like a fake sometimes oh
yeah I mean what we were just talking
about with um the speaking thing like I
have the voice in my head Stephen like
you've been coaching and working with
people for over 20 years like why are
you how do you still have anxiety about
getting up on a stage I can see emotion
in your face oh totally because it's
like so much
judgment like it's still there even
though I do it it's but it's like I
talked to my best friend about this all
the time and she was like Marie you're
doing great but I was like I still have
that voice that's like you should be
able to just walk up on any stage at a
moment's notice and like [ __ ] crush
it but it's just not the truth I can't
do that and so that voice is still there
and when I hear it I continue to
practice to be kind to myself and go
it's okay you're doing okay
do you feel like you're enough
I and I'm better at this than I've ever
been I'm not nowhere near perfect please
no but I am so much less susceptible
Than I Used to Be
you know like I was telling you about
that person that said you're so good at
what you do like why aren't your numbers
bigger that conversation
I felt like such [ __ ] right and it was
just like oh God you know like you have
you've been doing it why aren't your
numbers bigger like so that if I'm in if
I get sucked into that conversation I
absolutely do not feel like enough a
hundred percent when I have enough
perspective or when I can you know what
I mean like get sober from that I'm like
dude everything is like I'm so happy how
do I get sober from that
one of the ways that I did I realized
that uh for me and this was just me
personally
being on social was not healthy for me
it was not because you know in any given
moment you're either like engaged in
your life and creating and like just
being with people you're making a meal
or you know like whatever you do or for
me like even just being on there it's
like it's almost like a little thought
worm gets in and then at two o'clock in
the morning you wake up and you're like
why am I not doing x and x like so and
so is or I should be doing this like
it's that whole conversation I should be
wanting this or I should be doing this
and I found it to be really toxic for me
I found it to be really unhealthy for me
where I was like wow if I'm on this
thing I find that I'm comparing myself
and when I'm not on this thing I'm like
yeah like I'm so happy I'm CR like I'm
really creatively productive I'm more
prolific like I'm a better leader I'm a
better partner I'm just happy so I
actually don't spend hardly any I like
don't do it at all there'll be people
you know that want to be coaches or that
yeah because you careers in creating
that yes that feel the same way yeah but
they could buy my business yeah how do I
how am I going to be successful in my
business if I'm not on social media sure
sure I think that there are really
helpful and useful ways to do so and I
think that it doesn't have to take a lot
of money it just takes a little bit of
creativity and it takes some really
strong personal boundaries and standards
so for instance at this point in the
game
you know I have a team you've met some
of them today like we'll create content
and they'll post it it's not much
different than me with my YouTube show
or my podcast I'm not necessarily the
one going on YouTube to upload things
does that make sense
dude oh I have no money well this is
something you could probably get an
intern this is one of the things that's
everything is figure outable you can
absolutely figure it out like even if
you had to work a little bit extra if
you were a bartender like me or waiting
tables and one of your shifts was
devoted to hiring someone to post things
for you you could figure it out or you
could set limits for yourself you know
Instagram and I don't know because I
don't know much about the app because
I'm not in there much but um I know that
you can turn off or at least mine is you
don't have to see the amounts of likes
on anything you just actually see an
image or whatever and so you can kind of
craft the tools so that you keep
yourself away from the things that [ __ ]
you up yeah and then you go on and I
showed this to an artist friend of mine
who is absolutely drowning because she
was comparing herself to all these other
artists and I showed her how to mute
things because she loves those human
beings but it's just her own ego gets so
such right so it's like she wishes all
of these people well she's a beautiful
person who wants everybody to be
successful but like most of us it's
built into our neurology it's built into
our biology to compare ourselves and if
you spend enough time on that you're
gonna wind up feeling like [ __ ] it's
funny you said something earlier where
we were talking about kids and you said
the advice you'd like to give to women
is just all the The Narrative you'd like
to put out there to women is that by the
way it is a choice yeah no one ever said
that to me about social media that like
I could be intentional yes about how I
use it we download the app it says put
your name in we do as we're told and
then it quite clearly because of the
comparison psychology we're like okay I
need to make this number bigger and
these numbers as big as possible that's
what I'm doing here
the pause I had maybe a couple of years
ago was like
the harm is done in I'm choosing to
follow people and this like a library is
now the greatest influence over my world
view my view of myself in the world is
the me just hitting that follow button
I'll follow Kim Kardashian Kylie oh this
account's called get rich become a
millionaire and it's posting
Lamborghinis follow and what you're
doing is you're populating your library
with junk values and then you're going
to pay the price you're going to pay the
price for that so this idea that I could
just mute everyone
came to me maybe three years ago and
honestly if you're listening to this and
I follow you there's a reason why I'm
not in your story views because 95
percent of people are muted
the people that really matter have my
WhatsApp they send me like inappropriate
gifts and completely memes and stuff
like you know where I'm at yep so yeah
and I'd never post anything personal in
terms of what I'm doing in my life where
I go on holiday what I drive whatever on
there anyway I don't want to play those
games I post ideas yeah and um I
actually don't post myself either
because I'm fortunate enough to have a
team but yeah that that point about
being really intentional about the tools
and that is you know that's really the
key point because all the rest of it and
and there is to you know it's not like I
haven't I have posted and if I was
starting over again and I felt like that
was actually a good tool for my message
to get out and I said okay this is great
for me how can I batch yeah how can I do
this and get great I'm going to schedule
this up they're scheduling there's all
kinds of different tools and to your
point I loved the word that you used how
can I be intentional about this how can
I use this medium in a way that's going
to help me serve and connect with people
that I really want to connect with and
absolutely minimize or eliminate the
downsides and you can and you can and I
think that's what's really really
important and I think there's too many
people who think that you have to be on
it all the time and for some people if
they enjoy it I'll meet like go on with
your bad self I just realized that's not
me we don't realize the role that media
is having on our values and our psyche
and our mental health and our well-being
um I read this wonderful study he
basically exposed them to certain media
um to an advert with a toy in it the
children that watch the advert with the
toy in it versus the children that
didn't watch the advert with a toy in it
were then asked who do you want to play
with a really nasty person a really mean
person that's holding the toy or a
really wonderful human being A really
lovely kid that didn't have the toy
those that had seen the advert the kids
that had seen the advert always chose to
go and hang around with and play with
the nasty kid with the toy and what that
shows is how the media that influence
the glamorization of that toy shifted
your values at a really fundamental
level and if you think about that you
zoom out on an adult's life and how
something they see consume in this
Digital Library can make them skew their
orientation towards junk values and how
that will lead them to like
unfulfillment a burnout ad connections
bad relationships you've got to be
intentional yes about that Library I'll
say one thing too that I've shared with
my audience that maybe some folks in
yours will find useful especially if you
are a person who consumes social media
or other media content when you first
wake up in the morning I think 85
percent of folks who own cell phones do
create before you consume
create before you consume whether it's
creating a stronger mindset a stronger
body spending time in nature being with
your partner writing that song creating
that piece of art just create before you
consume and it's like a really fun
Mantra that you can use anytime during
the day like if you're going to pick up
your phone because you're insecure
you're uncertain you're uncomfortable
you're fearful you don't know what to do
next so you're like well let me go for
my little you know addict thing create
before you consume let it be a pause and
ask yourself what do I really want to
create right now do I want to consume
other people's ideas do I want to get
sucked into this hole or is there
something I want to create is there a
meal I want to make is there a walk I
want to take is there a friend I want to
reach out to do I want to take a picture
and send it to my best friend and say oh
my God I'm thinking of you you know
whatever it is but this notion of just
creating before we consume again that's
just been another one that's helped me
it's so powerful it's so simple
and I definitely need to heed that
advice because I wake up and I look at
my what's happening and say oh [ __ ]
especially when you've got like Global
like businesses in different time zones
sure waking up to a crisis every day is
not the best place but listen Marie um
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the previous guest asks a
question in the Diary of a CEO which is
on the table here this is the official
Diary of a CEO this is the one of one
um where they ask a question for the
next guest they don't know who they're
asking it for and I don't get to see it
until I open the book
so here we go handwriting is interesting
so give me a second
um
what lesson have you learned from your
lowest point
and is there anything about it that
you're grateful for
um
I don't know if there's one specific
lowest point but I'll just I'll I'll
choose one
the lesson
that I learned from a low point
was to
always trust my instincts and to not
Outsource
wisdom to not Outsource what I should do
to not look to other people
to find the wisdom that already is
within me and I think that trusting of
that little voice and to never ever ever
ever doubt it
that was probably
um that's the lesson I I keep getting in
my life and I I keep adhering to and
learning on different levels and am I
grateful for it 100 because I feel like
every time I have a low point and
struggle and go within rather than go
without
I develop an intimate relationship even
deeper with myself and I have a greater
level of trust and faith that not only
is everything figure outable but that
there is a a higher intelligence there
is a greater wisdom that is absolutely
on my side and that it has nothing to do
with external tools or external people
or external expectations and then if I'm
quiet enough and courageous enough to be
still the answers Within
when was that lowest point
the one I was thinking of uh was
actually
when
Josh and I were sitting on the couch and
he told me I don't think I love you
anymore I think this is done
and I
was in such shock this was remember we
were talking about how there was like a
we've had many ups and downs but this
was one where we were sitting and I was
looking at him and I felt that his heart
was like so not available it wasn't just
a normal fight
and Stephen my gut dropped and I felt
it was like all the oxygen got sucked
out of the room
and I felt like I had [ __ ] up the best
relationship that I had ever had with my
work addiction
and I remember it was a moment of either
like feeling fearful like okay this is
done and I need a defense mechanism
which would be some version of screw you
get out you know what I mean like fine
it's over
and then I said I remember saying he
said I don't I don't think I love you
anymore and I said that's not true
it's like this is not over and but it
did not come from like it sounds super
aggressive I know that that sounds
really scary but there was and I'm not
kidding you there was this inner voice
that I was like he's hurt you're hurt
fight for this
fight for this relationship do not let
this go so that in her voice you know
it's easy especially for someone like me
when when I can get hurt like there's a
somewhat of a natural or at least back
at that time to be defensive right and
say you know I don't love you I'm this
is done I'm walking out I don't need you
and I was like you [ __ ] be humble and
you fight for this relationship and I
remember sitting there and telling him
that this wasn't over I understand that
he believes he doesn't love me anymore I
said I still love you more than anything
and I'm willing to do whatever it takes
to see if this can be repaired and I
asked him I said I'm willing to do
anything we can go to therapy we
whatever but are you willing to at least
take a step to see if it's possible
because I think this is the greatest
love of my life and I don't want to lose
you
and
I saw something in him crack meaning
that I could see he was hurt and he
didn't know I cared that much and I
think it took me being so a little bit
aggressive but also really loving in
that moment and saying I am willing to
fight for this and I don't want to lose
you and yeah I've probably been an
[ __ ] but I'm willing to work on it
and I want to fix it and so it was that
inner voice that there was like [ __ ] him
like you know it was like leave whatever
but the deeper voice said fight for this
and I'm so grateful that I listened to
that rather than the whiny egoic
voice that was just you know hurt and
felt rejected
Mary thank you
thank you for um
I mean it's so much I mean I could sit
here and talk to you for five hours
around all of these topics because I
learned so much you've got such a
[ __ ] free
um experience based wise unique
perspective on challenges that so many
people are solving and these are all the
most important challenges that your book
everything is figureoutable is full of
solutions to the most important
challenges that I get every day that's
why I said to you before we started
recording it was so hard to try and
condense my notes on this conversation
because these are all the questions that
I'm being asked and you've answered them
in an original a thoughtful and
inexperienced based way from your own
truth um not from something you've read
somewhere or from cliche that is so
important and also time genius
I mean your description of that
uh I mean it rings true to so many
people in my life I think maybe too many
people in my life so it's wonderful that
you've got a resource out there that
everyone can access that I have no no
doubt in my mind that they will
that will really go to serve people and
help them go on that journey of finding
out their true fulfilled self and
aligning themselves a little bit better
against that external voice
um and a little bit closer to that
internal voice thank you for your time
thank you for your wisdom your honesty
your vulnerability and everything you're
doing for so many people because it's
really important and you know I think a
lot about the coaching space and it's
heavily dominated especially at the top
by men
um Tony Robbins you know you think you
think about all these individuals
um and they don't have the same
experience they don't have the same
insight into
um what it is to be a woman as well that
is
um go struggling with an external
narrative from from society that people
like me as a man would never really
understand
but your work your work appeals to both
and that's um
that's special so thank you thank you
for giving me your time thank you so
much for having me on it was an absolute
joy and an honor quick one as you might
know crafted are one of the sponsors of
this podcast and crafted are a jewelry
brand and they make really meaningful
pieces of jewelry I think I've worn this
piece for almost a year it hasn't broken
hasn't changed color because it's really
really good quality and it costs roughly
50 Quid I'm not the type of person that
has Rolexes or jewelry that cost tens of
thousands of pounds I want pieces that
are reliable that look beautiful and
that holds meaning and significance for
me and that's exactly why I've worn
crafted for so long and when we have the
conversation about them sponsoring this
podcast I was so unbelievably Keen for
them to do so check it out if you're a
guy crafted london.com and yeah if you
get any pieces of crafted tag man let me
know what you think
foreign